hi I'm Eric Voss and the new Halloween
film is the fright you're looking for
this season that is if your greatest
fear is a gun-wielding woods woman
screaming at you while you're
trick-or-treating I think part of the
reason this 2018 Halloween has been so
successful is the way the movie
recreates the classic imagery and setups
from the original John Carpenter classic
and that includes an intentionally
mysterious ending now I have already
gone into the mysteries of Halloween's
ending and it's secret post-credit
moment in another video definitely go
watch that but we just learned that
there was an alternate ending and we can
actually piece together from leaked
drafts of the old script and deleted
scenes shown in the trailers what that
alternate ending was so let's break it
all down and spoiler warning if you
haven't seen Halloween yet okay as you
know if you've seen the movie Halloween
ends with Laurie Strode Jamie Lee Curtis
confronting Michael Myers in her remote
home in the woods which she fortified a
booby trapped in case he ever escaped
and came after her and the version we
saw Laurie initially sent her daughter
Karen Judy Greer into the panic room
under the kitchen while trying at first
to keep Michael out of the house but he
gets in anyway and Laurie hunts him down
room by room sweeping through and
blocking off every room and they
eventually meet face to face in an
upstairs room which Michael filled with
Laurie's target mannequins here they
both get in a couple nasty hits before
Michael throws her out the window over
the balcony while this is going on
Laurie's granddaughter Alison finally
catches up to the house and joins her
mother Karen down in the panic room
Michael tries to get to them but
Laurie's stabs him from behind Karen
shoots him in the face with her
childhood rifle and the three women
trapped Michael Myers down the panic
room and it's revealed to be a cage of
its own and Laurie torches the house so
Laurie Karen and Alison escape in the
back of a truck meanwhile Michaels body
has never shown suggesting that he could
have once again disappeared into the
night and of course at the end of the
credits you can hear the sound of
Michael breathing fine that's exactly
the case however if you watched every
single trailer shot like a crazy you may
remember a brief shot of Laurie and
Michael engaging in a knife fight in the
yard outside Laurie's home kitchen knife
against kitchen knife this shot was
actually part of the movie's original
ending in we could see what that ending
was by reading a final couple pages of
an old draft of the film script that was
written by Jeff Radley Danny McBride and
David Gordon Green in this alternate
version Alison arrives at Laurie's house
earlier when Laurie is still in the
middle
her confrontation with Michael Myers
downstairs by the front door and Michael
referred to as the shape in the script a
reference to the original credit Nick
castle received in the first movie
appears in the doorway on the front
porch and Laurie fires her last shot of
him but misses this leads to a classic
showdown with Laurie charging Michael
like a mama bear and taking him on
outside where their blades meet Michael
ends up stabbing her in the chest and
Laurie slices his arm he's already
losing blood from when Laurie shot off
his fingers they're both wounded it
could really go either way and in this
alternate version this is where Laurie's
daughter Karen Judy Greer emerges from
the basement panic room actually in this
older draft her name was Shanna or Shana
that was changed to Karen and instead of
her childhood rifle she holds a high
tech crossbow now there's a [ __ ]
missing at this point from the old
script but presumably Shanna
Karen shot Michael with this crossbow
and a woman exchanged some words and
they run out to the road where we see on
page 94 they waved down a truck and then
they escape and this final page leaves
us with Michael alone in the woods among
all the mannequins he sits by a tree and
he touches his wounds breathing
listening to sirens in the distance and
the final words say his breathing
deepens exhausted or possibly his works
okay this sounds like a very clear set
up for a sequel with the final question
being will this still alive Michael
Myers live long enough to kill again
instead of the theatrical version we all
saw leaving us with the question where
the hell is Michael is he alive at all
you'll also notice that well unless they
crammed a lot on that missing page 93 of
the old draft the old version did not
include most of the cool stuff that we
saw in the actual climax of the final
cut Laurie sweeping through the rooms of
the house Laurie fighting Michael in
that room that he filled with her
mannequins Michael throwing Laurie over
the balcony and Laurie stealing his move
from the first movie and pretending to
be dead but then slipping away Karen
pretending to panic and luring Michael
down to the panic room but then shooting
them with the rifle
Laurie jumping out from the shadows
stabbing Michael and the three women
torching the house according to some
unconfirmed statements by people
claiming to have seen test screenings
with the alternate ending the ending
without all this stuff came off as
laughably bad and necessitated a reshoot
to put all this new climactic stuff in
and yeah this is unconfirmed I don't
know which version people actually saw
there's probably a lot of versions that
were tested in front of audiences so we
don't really know if this original
ending was really that bad but this
script does prove that Laurie did
one point faced Michael one-on-one with
the kitchen knife and that Michael
sitting among Laurie's mannequins was at
one point the movies final image not as
we saw a move that Michael made inside
Laurie's house now on the page I
definitely feel the catharsis of Laurie
confronting her mortal enemy with the
same weapon he came after her with all
those years ago the kitchen knife but
the additions to the final theatrical
cut bring even more symbolic reversals
into the film's climax which I go into
super in-depth in my breakdown of the
movie now Laurie's overall defense
against Michael has multiple steps
vindicating each of her seemingly
paranoid precautions around her house
has actually useful and building up to a
fiery climax with several fun callbacks
to the original classic and compared to
the ending that appears on the page in
the leaked script the one we saw gives
us a lot more payoff leaving Michael
Myers is fade a lot more open-ended
because as we learn in movies like Jaws
and in carpenter's classic it's always
scarier to keep the monster out of frame
keep us guessing but my question for you
is which ending do you prefer the final
cut ending that we saw in the movie or
the original ending that we now read in
the script comment down below with your
thoughts and follow me on twitter and
instagram at a basa and subscribe to me
rock stars for deep dives of everything
that you love horror movies and Marvel
and Star Wars Game of Thrones and to
thank you for sticking around to the end
of this video here is a bonus sneak peek
at this video's original alternate
ending thanks for watching everyone and
uh here's my audition for The Voice
watches over me
what no we're not gonna reshoot this mmm
yeah yeah you were right to take that
out
[Music]